chère communauté d intérêts web j'ai
fait une connerie dans ma dernière vidéo
est plutôt que de la supprimer et de
corriger
je me suis dit que le mieux était encore
de faire une petite vidéo à propos de
cette connerie donc ça va être un peu
différente d'habitude et comme je veux
faire vite yoram en images désolé alors
voilà ces dernières vidéos elle abordait
la question de l' approche quantitative
de la connaissance en gros est ce qu en
savoir plus c'est forcément mieux
alors que j'écrivais le script je
cherchais à illustrer un truc qu'on vit
quand on creuse un sujet au début on
connaît trois fois rien et à mesure
qu'on fait des recherches on développe
notre culture relative à ce sujet et
quand on se rappelle nos débuts on se
dit c'est fou comme je ne pouvais pas
imaginer ce que je vais découvrir
ensuite puisque je cherchais un exemple
pour illustrer sa et parce que j'ai un
cerveau humain donc essentiellement
flemmard j'ai choisi le premier truc qui
m'est venue en tête à savoir ce que j'ai
moi même vécu en découvrant la poésie
française et le problème c'est que j'ai
pas réfléchi deux secondes à mon exemple
je me suis pas dit qu'il y avait un
quelconque enjeu puisque de toute façon
dans ma tête c'était uniquement pour
illustrer j'aurais pu prendre n'importe
quoi la peinture expressionniste la
musique baroque ou l'histoire des
vikings et donc j'ai été au plus simple
à savoir j'ai été chercher dans ma
mémoire
quelques-unes des figures qui ont
jalonné mon propre parcours dans la
poésie française
et comme je suis le produit d'une
société sexiste qui a rendu invisible
les poétesses j'ai balancé une liste
composée de dix hommes j'ai pas eu à
attendre très longtemps avant de me
rendre compte
une personne de mon entourage très
proche donc qui me connaît très bien
genre depuis très longtemps m'a appelé
pour me confier avoir été choqué de
cette absence de femme et moi évidemment
j'ai été d'autant plus emmerdé que ça
venait d'une personne qui me connaît
très bien quelqu'un connais mes
engagements
quelqu'un qui suit mon travail c'est à
dire quelqu'un qui sait en l'occurrence
que par ailleurs j'ai publié des
poétesses dans ma revue que je parle du
sexisme avec mes étudiants en classe et
que j'ai lancé une chaîne youtube qui se
veut autant que possible inclusive à
excuser mon retard emma lourdeur mais là
je suis obligé de saisir l'occasion pour
afficher mes poètes est préféré
si quelqu'un qui me connaît si bien et
choqué par ce passage je me dis que
l'effet est potentiellement
catastrophique auprès des inconnus alors
oui bien sûr je pourrais me dire tu n'as
pas fait une vidéo sur la poésie
cela représente seulement 30 secondes à
peine dans une vidéo de 30 minutes
c'est anecdotique je pourrais aussi me
dire tu étais fatigué tu as laissé
passer une connerie c'est un hobby c'est
tout sauf que non je ne peux pas dire ça
d'abord parce que et c'est ironique dans
cette vidéo j'ai justement dit que
l'intention ne pesait pas bien lourd
devant les conséquences réelles des
actes et j'ai aussi ajouté avoir
l'intention consciente de faire
attention aux autres ça très bien
beaucoup de maladresses beaucoup de
maladresses oui mais pas toutes les
maladresses
alors pour être honnête je me suis
retrouvé un peu pris de vertige c'est
pas tellement que ce soit surprenant
d'ailleurs mais démoralisant saint louis
si c'est effectivement mon intention
consciente de visibiliser des femmes et
des personnes racisées que j'y pense
grosso modo à chaque vidéo que j'écris
est que malgré ça j'ai des absences qui
me conduisent à faire une bourde
pareille ça soulève une question toute
simple est ce qu'ils voudraient pas
mieux que je me taise et là aussi c'est
ironique puisque cette dernière vidéo
appelé à la fin a travaillé pour
apprendre à écouter les autres et pas
pour imposer son point de vue est-ce que
c'était en fait adressé à moi même parce
que la question c'est aussi at on besoin
d'une énième chaîne youtube réalisé par
un homme si ce genre blanc hétérosexuel
valide dans la force de l'âge même s'il
a les tempes grisonnantes
est-ce qu'on peut raisonnablement croire
que ce genre de retour et guident ma
conscience du problème est qu'à l'avenir
je ne ferai plus jamais cette erreur je
suis pas sûr oui évidemment la prochaine
fois que je réalise et déploie tous des
artistes
je risque d'avoir une petite voix qui
résonne dans la tête et donc on peut
choisir d'être optimiste il se dire qu'à
chaque erreur on progresse mais il ya
tellement d'autres injustices sociales
que je ne subis pas quotidiennement
je me dis que je vais forcément
entretenir certaines représentations
sociales toxiques sans m'en rendre
compte
la question de nos malheurs ce que
j'apporte qu'on pense t-il les
inévitables maladresse et autres
oublient à venir une autre personne dans
mon entourage proche m'a encouragé à
continuer en me disant que c'est
précisément parce que les hommes 6
blancs hétérosexuels ont davantage de
visibilité qu'il faut qu'ils abordent
ces sujets elle m'a alors conseillé de
regarder cet épisode formidable de la
suite' tonight que je vous recommande
chaudement il porte sur les billets en
médecine aux états unis les femmes et
personnes racisées ne reçoivent pas la
même qualité de traitement
john oliver commencer aussi peut-être
que oui ça marche avec lui parce qu'en
fait m'a dit c'est lui qui parle
ce qu'il énonce et préparé par une
équipe composée de point de vue
diversifiés et avec des moyens autrement
plus important que le mien donc là ok
sans doute que c'est une bonne chose que
le plus blanc des hommes blancs prennent
la parole mais honnêtement dans mon cas
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit c'est
justifié ce n'est pas comme si j'avais
une expertise précise dont on a besoin
du coup je m'interroge sur le sens de ce
travail oui le point de départ c'est l
envie d'aider c'est le sentiment que
j'ai compris des trucs qui m'ont aidé à
vivre et que ça peut donc en aider
d'autres mais si en fait ça aide surtout
ceux qui me ressemble et qu'au passage
j'écrase les pieds de celles et ceux qui
sont différents de moi c'est franchement
pas sûr que ça vaille le coup
bon bien sûr c'est un peu ridicule d'en
parler comme ça comme si j'avais douze
mille abonnés et tout je veux pas faire
le mec dramatique
donc je ne fais pas cette petite vidéo
pour avoir des commentaires du genre va
pas c'est pas l'idée est la limite je me
demande ce que vous en pensez de manière
générale quand est ce qu'on peut dire
d'une chaîne youtube qu'elle fait plus
de bien que de mal
c'est pas si évident en tout cas tant
que je ne trouve pas de réponse précise
à cette question je crois que ça
m'impose un changement de ton ou de
méthode disons si je veux éviter les
erreurs comme celle ci peut-être qu'il
faut simplement changer d'angle d'
approche non pas dire les choses telles
que je les voyais comprendre mais plutôt
raconter les questions que je me pose
basculer de l'affirmatif al interrogatif
il ya plein de gens qui font un super
boulot hyper informés et qu'ils en
savent mille fois plus que moi sur la
société
donc je vais essayer d'apprendre à la
ferme est un peu par là j'entends déjà
prendre un peu de temps pour réfléchir à
tout ça et puis essayer à l'avenir à
part si je lance une série sur un
domaine que je maîtrise un peu de me
contenter de poser des questions
finalement c'est aussi un peu à ça que
ça sert la philosophie à poser des
questions qui ouvre les perspectives et
en y réfléchissant je me dis que c'est
sûrement ce que j'ai de mieux à proposer
partager des questionnements plutôt que
des explications
donc voilà la prochaine on va bien voir
à quoi ça ressemble